- [Narrator] When Pfizer first reported
the efficacy of their COVID-19 vaccine,
a staggering 95%,
many thought that would
mark an end to the pandemic,
but that hasn't happened.
Vaccination rates have remained low
in certain parts of the world,
despite multiple available vaccines.
And there's also been reports
of breakthrough cases,
where fully-vaccinated people get COVID.
And now, recent unpublished
data from Israel showed,
that the Pfizer vaccine
was only 40% effective
at reducing the risk of symptomatic COVID.
So if the original trials
showed high efficacy,
why did a large portion of
people in this Israeli study
get COVID?
Here's why those two
numbers are so far apart
and why neither of them
can tell the full story.
To understand this gap,
first, you need to
understand the difference
between efficacy and effectiveness.
Vaccine efficacy refers to
how well a vaccine performs
under ideal, tightly
controlled conditions,
like clinical trials.
For example, during trials for COVID-19,
vaccines were given to
people on a tight schedule.
It also has to do with what
the researchers were studying.
Here, they were looking at
how well vaccines prevented
symptomatic infections in
a limited number of people,
not whether they prevented
infection altogether,
or kept people from being contagious.
And with COVID-19, it's
possible to be infected
and not show symptoms.
- What determines how efficacious,
or how well the vaccine works in a trial,
is really two things.
- [Narrator] Lisa Lee has
studied the spread of viruses
for 30 years,
and has held leadership roles at the CDC.
- It's how contagious the virus is,
how many people an infected
person might infect
in the absence of that vaccine.
And it also depends a lot
on the host, that is people.
How well can the vaccine stimulate
the right immune response for people?
- [Narrator] In Pfizer study,
the company tested about 44,000 people
for symptomatic COVID-19,
and only 170 develop the disease
with at least one symptom.
And of those, just eight
had been vaccinated,
while 162 had gotten the placebo.
This is what added up to
that 95% efficacy rate.
This by the way, means that
in a vaccinated population,
95% fewer people will contract the disease
when they come in contact with the virus,
not that each individual is 95% immune.
But that efficacy rate was
calculated during a specific time
and under a specific set of circumstances.
Many people were staying at home,
avoiding large gatherings, wearing masks,
and the virus hadn't mutated as much.
Vaccine effectiveness, on the other hand,
is how well a vaccine
works in the real world,
outside of clinical settings,
where it's harder to control variables
that were constant in a study,
like when people get their vaccines.
- You know, the real
world is kind of messy.
Not everybody gets their
vaccines at the exact interval.
Not everybody has the same
kind of immune system.
- [Narrator] And behavior is changing too.
In many places, businesses are open,
and large gatherings are happening again.
This is part of why
efficacy numbers in trials
are often higher than the effectiveness
we see in the real world.
And what makes this all
the more complicated
is that the virus itself
is still evolving.
The Delta variant,
which has become dominant
in multiple countries,
is more transmissible than
earlier strains of the virus,
which means that more people
will come in contact with it.
It became dominant,
months after the vaccines
had been authorized,
and millions of doses
had been distributed.
That means our current shots were designed
for an earlier version of the coronavirus
and don't work as well against Delta.
This is part of why we're hearing more
about breakthrough cases.
U.S. states counted over
190,000 breakthrough cases
between January 1st and
early August this year.
That's among millions who
are already vaccinated.
And remember that Israeli study,
data was collected for
it in June and July,
when Delta was dominant there.
Health officials saw breakthrough cases
were more likely among people
who had gotten the vaccine
early on, in January or February.
This is partly because antibodies,
which the body produces after the vaccine
to protect itself against the virus,
naturally decrease over time.
That, along with the
unknowns about variants,
is a big reason why the
Biden administration
announced new vaccine recommendations.
- We are announcing our plan
to stay ahead of this virus,
by being prepared to offer
COVID-19 booster shots,
to fully-vaccinated
adults, 18 years and older.
- What we want to do is make sure
that we keep that immunity high enough,
so when it starts to wane,
we want to make sure that people
are able to get that third shot.
- [Narrator] That should
increase the chances
that the vaccines prevent severe illness
that could then lead to
hospitalization and death.
Still, there is some debate
among public health experts
as to whether booster
shots are needed right now,
that's because antibodies are
not the body's only defense
against the virus.
There are also certain immune cells
that prepare the body
to fight off pathogens,
and those may not be waning.
And while breakthrough
cases continued to occur,
experts say that these
cases are usually mild
and don't result in severe illness.
Let's go back to that Israeli data
that showed that the Pfizer vaccine
is now only 40% effective
against symptomatic COVID.
Well, that same study
showed that the vaccine,
had a 91% effectiveness against
hospitalization and death.
- The vaccine really,
what it does is help us
slow the speeding car,
and it helps us to reduce transmission.
And that is what's gonna
get us out of this pandemic.
- [Narrator] In addition to vaccines,
experts also recommend preventive
measures like mask wearing
and social distancing to
keep the virus from spreading
and mutating further.
(tense music)